[MUSIC]
>> Hi, I'm Anna Roth from the
Microsoft Cognitive Services
Computer Vision Team.
Today I'm here talking about our
custom vision service.
So the custom vision service,
which is available at
customvision.ai is a service for
helping people build their own
custom image classifiers, so
recognize objects or things that
they care about.
In this example, I have built a
classifier to recognize plants
that are available at the
Japanese Garden in Seattle.
I want to be able to recognize
things like a Japanese pine, a
cypress or a Japanese maple.
The way that you do this is you
upload some example images, say
maybe 50 images per class, and
then all you have to do is hit
train and you have a classifier
that's hosted for you at an API,
at an http endpoint.
So I've already built my
classifier and trained it, and I
have it right here.
Now I'm going to run a quick
test to see if it's working.
So I'm doing a quick test here.
And I'll just grab an image that
I took earlier, that I had from
earlier.
It's a picture of a Japanese
maple.
Let's see if we get this right.
So I've uploaded the image here
And then with very, very high
confidence, the trends of my
classifier predicted that it's a
Japanese maple.
The other neat thing about this
system is that every image that
you send for classification is
saved.
So all these images that I
submitted previously have been
saved here.
I can actually go label them and
then over time improve my
classifier.
So the custom vision service is
a really, really easy way for
anybody to build a classifier in
a couple of minutes and improve
it over time.
I hope you'll give it a chance
to try it out.
You can do so by going to
customvision.ai.
That's customvision.ai and give
it a shot today.
Thank you.